Hey,
what's going it's Bill Burr.
It's time for Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast at [inaudible].
Just checking in on you.
How are you hanging with my wife on a rainy day and fucking Aaron.
Hey,
what's up?
Hi.
How are Ya?
Nia.
There was a reason I brought you on this podcast.
And what does that reason?
Well,
Nia,
as you know,
I am a blowhard.
Yes.
I talk and talk and talk and talk to the point that I fall asleep.
There you go.
I was waiting.
Um,
so I actually ran to a question the other day.
Believe it or not,
I'm walking on it.
right?
Let's use it.
Ah,
walking on air.
So I'm on sended me a fucking question.
I couldn't answer it.
It blew my mind because even if I don't know the answer,
I still fucking talk to these people.
There you go.
All right,
well that's a great song.
Let me get that piece of fun.
Get a piece of fuzz off your Mike.
This chairs are not as comfortable as they look.
Well,
they're made for men.
That's why these are men chairs.
I need an Ottoman.
These are anti beach.
Okay.
All right.
But in England,
a man like you have,
how come there's not a second Ottoman for this chair?
Because this is,
this is a loaners.
You keep calling this a man cave.
It's not a man cave.
I don't call it a man cave.
All in a man cave.
It's my office.
I don't ever call it a man cave.
I never call it that.
Wow.
Just like that on the podcast.
You're going to lie.
I've never said I was going.
You can go to your office.
That's what I want.
I'm vanishing from that.
Wow.
What?
Nia.
I don't think that I called it a man cave.
Oh,
now you're backing down from it yet.
I believe you called this gas lighting.
You're making me seem like I'm crazy.
Maybe I'm crazy.
Anyway,
so this person had a question and it's a very delicate subject.
Near
alright.
Delicate like my feelings.
You know,
people's,
not much as I go on stage night after night and I tried to act like I'm this
tough person.
If you really took the time to know me,
you'd know that it was volition.
It's true.
Oh,
I'm just talk so much shit.
See,
this is the problem.
This is why people,
oh boy.
It's like,
people really think it's interesting to me how well your fans think they know
you because you have this persona onstage and you're the angry guy and that's
certainly true.
Blue lemme tell Ya.
But you're also just so full of shit.
Like you just talk someone like you're all talk,
you just talk and talk and talk,
but you're just full of shit because you are such a sensitive,
like giving like you know it's good shit.
Yeah.
But it's annoying because it's like you're walking around like,
hey,
Yay,
Yay.
You know like choking
the fucking microphone stand like you do.
Like it's weird to take the good with the bed.
People are like,
Oh God,
you guys went to Paris.
I met bill hated that.
And it's like,
no,
it's actually like his favorite city.
Oh Wow.
You guys went to the beach and all.
I bet bill hated that.
No,
we actually had a good time.
Like,
it's just so weird.
There's like this disconnect with Pete and you please.
Duty Fan again.
Oh,
I bet.
I believe that that's what it is.
It's always like,
Oh God,
I bet bill hated that.
And also it's like anytime I post any kind of picture on Instagram,
all of your fans,
God love Ya,
but all of your fans are like,
oh,
I bet bill.
You know,
they just will find something to bring you into it.
It'll be like a post to my feed.
Like,
oh,
Billy likes to no shoes or whatever the fuck it is.
It's like,
it's,
it's crazy.
What's wrong with that?
I mean,
nothing,
but it's just annoying.
Wow.
All that Yellen,
that's all you had.
I know.
I remember.
I really don't like,
I was like,
she ran out of steam.
You're going to knock me out for lunch.
You know,
it's rainy day.
I really wanted to go take a nap right now.
Dragged me up here.
It didn't suck the I for two in that place.
I know for two it's not bad.
Everything in there is good.
I just never ordered the good stuff.
Yeah,
I tried it.
I decided to take a risk and it didn't quite pay off,
but it was still nice to have lunch with you.
I know.
And then [inaudible] eating too much food.
No,
it must done.
But that we were eating the food and we realized we ordered too much,
so we cancel one of the pizzas.
Right.
Then he'd go,
which pizza do you want to cancel?
Yeah,
we should have canceled my pizza.
Yeah.
And I didn't want to fucking offend you getting all fucking pizza.
[inaudible] if I say abusing my a white male privilege by saying,
let's just get the simple sausage one.
Yeah,
you had to go with the fucking Wiener Schnitzel.
Whatever the hell you got it.
Yeah.
That didn't quite pay off.
It was still good,
but it just wasn't satisfying,
I think is the word you're looking for.
Are you impressed how I've been getting up early and going to the gym?
Not really.
I mean,
you're still on European time,
so it's actually not that impressive.
Oh,
we'll be right back with searching for a compliment.
Am I impressed with you for being legs until jetlag?
No,
that's fun.
Present.
Maybe.
You know why it has nothing to do with me being jet lagged because you snore
like a fucking offensive lineman.
Here we go on the snoring thing.
I gotta tell you as you go through these periods,
you have such a cute little nose.
How does,
I'll let noise noise come out of there because I'm sleeping hard and I'm
sleeping right.
I tell you that this thing that you're doing now where every fucking five
minutes you're shaking me in the bed like that doesn't do anything.
Let's explain.
Wakes you up and you stop for a second.
Oh shoot.
She starts fucking storm
on this shit.
So what I do is I'm laying on my side away from our end and what I do is I just
started shaking the bed.
I don't got it solved now and it wakes her up and she'd be like,
Huh,
what did I know?
The second you close your eyes.
Yeah.
It doesn't stop me from snoring.
So I like,
what is the point of units I love really starting to Piss me off.
Well I told you I will fucking,
I'll sleep somewhere else.
Okay.
All right.
But I've done that before and then after two nights you're like,
Yo,
Yo Yo,
welcome.
We with me.
Well,
so what are we supposed to do?
I snore.
You wake up.
We don't want to sleep apart from each other.
Yes.
So what's the solution?
I'm ugly enough so I need as much beauty sleep.
I can get.
Don't say that.
But um,
but yeah,
um,
no,
I guess I could get one of those breathe right strips or something.
Like,
I dunno,
you're breathing wrong baby.
Cause I never used to snore like that before the baby,
so I don't know.
I just think you're extra tired.
I'm skewed toward the way I imagined I snore after,
um,
I drink like a third of bottle of fucking booze.
You were snoring earlier in the night when you first fell asleep last night
because I took that at times and I taking that to get myself back on and it's
fucking work.
Great.
Okay.
So I'm going,
I don't know.
I don't know what to tell you,
but I still love you,
right?
No,
I know that I won't be passed out laying next to you anymore.
Just up shaking the bed.
It's like,
why?
What is,
it just doesn't work.
It works.
A lot of times you roll over and know you stopped like 20 minutes,
but now,
now you're just like relentless.
She liked the fucking terminator is sleeping.
Tell me,
I think I blew you up or some shit.
You just fucking come back together again.
You start snorting.
All right,
well I'm sorry.
Right,
so why am I,
oh my God.
Go ahead.
Why am I here?
What'd you call me in here for?
What is the cause you know what I made of New Year's resolution that I wasn't
going to argue with you as much.
What's,
yeah,
you made a new year's resolution that you're not going to argue with me as much
and it's been working,
so I need you to explain this.
What does that mean?
I'm just going to agree with you.
Is that what you think that I want?
Yes.
Jesus Christ.
It's like no winning.
There's no winning.
I like arguing with you as it worked.
I'll just agree with you.
All right.
I'm not trying to like cut off like the balls of your opinion.
I just need you to not be an asshole about that.
I don't know how to do that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Come on.
I'm an asshole.
Yeah,
he married an asshole.
but the what?
But that's kind of not fair on your side,
which you married an asshole and now you want me to not be an asshole.
I didn't realize you were that big then that has
no,
I knew you were,
I know you weren't sure how you know what it is.
Cause I thought you were like a bad boy and then the bad boy turns into like a
bad man then.
No,
but you're not a bad boy.
You're just like,
you're just grumpy.
And before I was like,
oh you're edgy.
Like he's edgy.
Like it doesn't take any shit man.
That's cause you're a casting director.
You put me in this box,
man.
Yeah.
So good.
He could play 28 to 35 he's edgy.
You weren't even looking at me like a person.
No,
that's not true.
I thought you were amazing and you're really cool,
but I just feel like as you've gotten older,
you've just become like so cranky.
Somebody was like,
oh,
bill is going to make the best like cranky old man.
It's going to be hilarious.
And it's like,
yeah,
I have to live with that.
It's gotta be so hard.
It is so,
believe me.
Brave.
What am I going to call my memoir?
Surviving Bill Burger.
Yeah,
that's it.
Surviving Bill Burke becoming no,
it's just like I said,
it's annoying cause you're actually a very sweet person,
but everybody sees this,
uh,
this angry jackass and that's what the people want.
They don't.
Yes,
they like me.
Believe it or not.
There's people beyond the walls of this fucking relationship that actually liked
me,
that Brandon,
they don't have to live with me.
I know I'm difficult to live with.
I'm literally telling you I'm going to try to just fucking agree.
Whatever harebrained fucking idea you have,
that's going to take up the whole fucking day.
You want to go after the cocoa Moko woke us fucking thing all the way up to
five.
Yeah.
Let's just play off football going on.
I'll tape it.
You did not take my games while I was away.
I thought I'd take all your car dash in the horse.
Shit,
whenever you're asking me to take Sebastian,
did you take Sebastian on the fucking news store?
You miss that toe?
I forgot cause I get caught up with the baby and shit and I forget.
But I really thought that I taped all your games while you were gone because I
sat there when I searched one,
the other two came up so I was like,
oh great record record record.
Sebastian was on like the fucking NBC nightly news and he was walking around the
comedy store talking about the history of place.
It's online bill.
We can find it online,
but yes,
I did forget to Dvr it so I apologize for that.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
We'll,
we'll search for it online.
Wait for somebody to put it online too.
We need to go to couples.
Can we just work it all out in the podcast?
I'd love to go to couple's therapy.
Would you?
Why?
Because I feel like if there was another person there going,
hey,
you know,
maybe bill has a point.
I could win one once,
once,
just one squads.
In fact,
to find a way for you to admit that baby,
I am right.
I know I can be a fucking Douche.
You and a lot of them is the thing.
You just don't realize that you do.
Yeah,
that's,
that's probably the biggest mind fuck you've ever given me.
You win a lot of them.
You just don't realize you do.
So you're so good that even when I'm winning,
I feel like I lose.
That's what you're telling me.
Wow.
I am amazing.
That is an amazing skill.
I don't know if I'd be proud of it.
Fair enough.
Do you taking my lines?
I love it.
Fair enough.
Well,
you know what,
Nia,
we went out to lunch today.
We,
we,
uh,
we did some other things that I'm not allowed to talk about yet because the,
you know,
I have to wait until the official announcement comes about.
You know,
I am,
I'll give you an idea.
There's something that's going on with me and it rhymes with ranch.
Sessioning
hi.
And I fully support you.
Fully support 100%.
We're going to try to make this relationship work is I ran position from a
fucking Douche.
Ah,
no.
What have I loved you so much?
I transitioned to a woman that enjoyed the Kardashians.
That's not what I want my life.
That's not what
[inaudible]
Seth graph.
I think so.
Say it's so weird.
You know I watched that show but I,
I hate them.
It's like,
so it's such a weird thing.
I am.
I hate watching it.
Do you think?
I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
I don't believe in hate watching.
I think that's so juvenile and like ridiculous.
It's probably some sort of like this probably uh,
uh,
you know [inaudible] at some point you'll be able to get in trouble with that on
social media.
I'm sure.
Why you Renee Hill accused of hate watching?
I don't recall.
Hate watching,
but if I did hate watch,
I'd like to apologize to the producers at those shows.
I'm on my phone and I'm just kind of like in and out.
Like I don't even really know what's going on,
but it's just there and they're talking at me and I know I don't,
I don't have a good explanation for it.
It is what it is.
No one knew.
If you enjoy that show,
God damn it.
You Watch it.
Okay.
And I'll show you other terrible reality shows.
So what's your top three terrible reality shows?
Uh,
currently it's Vanderpump rules,
uh,
real housewives.
I don't mind Vanderpump rules,
you know?
Yeah.
You like those goods.
And I know it's just something like,
uh,
I don't get what's,
I don't understand how you get a job at a restaurant and your manager becomes
your life coach.
There's just something hilarious about that to me.
Yeah.
She's like the mother figure,
but it's just like a young [inaudible].
I can tell she married,
she married,
she's been married for like the longest side.
Kids of her own.
Her kids are grown up.
Okay.
She owns these businesses and then she employs,
he's like young,
beautiful fame whores and a deals while they're drama.
So the skinny dude who cried
[inaudible] Jane,
you're firing me.
Wait a minute.
You're firing me.
I love that she stuck to her guns.
She did.
That kid's a mess.
I deserves to be fired.
Well,
he doesn't need to get his life together.
You firing me?
Yes,
I know.
I don't even know what that happened.
It just seemed like it was the longest I've ever seen somebody.
He had no argument.
He just kept,
I don't know.
That's what it felt he was saying.
Um,
so they let that guy go.
He's fired off the show for what?
Not off the show.
He's still on the show.
He just,
because he gets really drunk and he says really nasty things to the people that
work there,
namely the girls,
and he's always like,
you all fat,
whore,
fucking hassle.
Oh,
that's fucking great.
I love that guy.
So far you haven't.
Then the other guy,
Jack's right.
I was hoping he's going to get the job of the hockey club.
Yeah,
right.
Here's the whole thing with all that.
He was going to tweet,
he's going to do social media for like a minor league,
Florida based hockey team.
So a bullshit job is that,
that's a chocolate shop.
Wow.
What kind of job is that to tweet for them and what way?
Got a game coming up.
Like that's really you're going to do for that Instagram account.
Yeah.
You're generating excitement.
You if this fights in this good hits and,
and it seems like a good game and people want to come out to buy tickets and
spend money yet that's what you do.
Okay,
well Christ near you can follow restaurants on Instagram.
I just started following this amazing cheeseboard account and you're making fun
of this guy with the hockey team cause somebody running a cheeseboard account.
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
Ain't too proud to mag because her name is meg Megan or those kinds of cheese.
I was like meg.
Oh it's incredible.
Munster cheese.
What are the cheeses?
Begin naming cheese that begins with them.
Monster.
Okay,
now you're the second person on the family feud.
You've got to come up with another one.
What do you go?
Mild Cheddar.
Cheddar.
Oh
wait,
why is that a bad cause?
The cheese.
It's got to be mild Cheddar.
No,
that's a kind of Cheddar.
Cheddar's see?
Hmm.
I Dunno.
You got some else?
Um,
Monterey.
Jack,
Monterey,
somebody.
Family members you can go to.
All right.
We as the unbelievable.
We'll name a cheese that begins with them.
We got Manchego man,
Shango.
Show me.
It's fucking unbelievable.
I love cheese.
All right.
This is fucking amazing.
Family number [inaudible] with chalk and cheese begins with an m with a lovely
necklace.
You Heather.
Richard.
Richard doesn't give me a kiss.
All right.
We need a cheese that begins with m or the Sullivan family has a chance to
steal.
What do you got?
Um,
I've got one strike with a mild cheese.
I honestly don't know any other cheeses.
I'd be going,
oh,
come on.
Give me a guess.
In three,
two,
one Montebello.
I do the Steve Harvey.
I asked you to name a cheese begins at m and you said Montebello.
I got nothing.
Show me Montebello.
I got no,
that's amazing that you could do that monsters all I had.
That's why I married you because you know all the cheeses.
[inaudible]
alright.
What do you want?
Do you want me to read the uh,
the advertising and then we'll do the question right.
Oh,
me undies.
Mandy's cutting of fucking cheese Doo Doo Doo.
Doo beyond ease me on the shit down to your knees,
running down your fucking tidy.
Whities it would be better if he had me undies and cradle that shit and no one
would know.
And your eyeballs feel nice and soft and a little warm.
Hmm,
sorry.
Wait,
can I interject real quick?
Sure.
Mandy is sent us some onesies and they are the most comfortable soft things ever
and I'd surely love them.
And this is not a part of what they asked us to read,
but like,
no,
they just want to say thank you.
Me On ds or the onesies and everyone.
I never got my z.
You did.
I put it on your,
your side of the bed.
I don't know what happened to him.
What happened to it?
Okay.
Are you going to,
where can we take a picture?
Uh,
I was a little weird to be an adult dressing like a six month old baby.
It's so comfortable.
Let's just a little more,
put it on and we'll take a picture and we'll post on Instagram and we'll do
Hashtag me on these Hashtag ad Hashtag spon con do you know what Spam Kaunas
nope.
Sponsored content.
Oh,
I'll tell you what.
I'm just going to read this article ad here.
That's what I'm gonna do right now.
I'm gonna agree with you.
Hey,
deal.
That sounds like great idea.
2019 bell at birth.
He's got no opinions here.
Alright.
Valentine's Day is right around the corner.
What are you going to get me to?
Why don't you fucking take me out this year?
It's taken a blow job,
please.
Nini,
rather than spending all that money going out to fancy restaurants,
why not just hang in,
hang in your underwear all night long courtesy of me undies.
They got that little trap door on the Monday so I can bang you from behind.
Talk about why me undies are the best underwear.
Feel free to improvise.
All right,
here we go.
I love fucking my wife in me on Z onesies.
All right,
I'm a minute man.
I'm done in one minute.
The whole thing,
just it all works.
Mianzhu ones.
He made a man's get it done before 8:00 PM seven minutes is fair.
Is that what I am?
Seven minutes is a great number.
I feel like that's fine.
You know what I mean?
It's fine.
I'm not trying to get banged like for hours on end.
It's like who has what you but you don't do any work.
You just fucking laying there and I'm up there like a fucking jackhammer.
What does,
what does,
what does Shelby fucking minutes I've got to do.
Could you do plank for seven minutes?
Cause that's what the fuck I have to do.
I got to get up off.
Yeah and drop it down.
Yeah.
You're not one of those cuddlers.
You're like get away from me.
Come back,
get away from me.
Come back.
I feel like a fucking astronaut spinning around with one's a little rubber balls
there.
Young undies uses,
uses the Covenant Micro Modal Modal Fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton.
Yes.
That's why that one's,
he was so comfortable.
Thank you fam.
The fabric generally feels like actual heaven against your skin.
This person was at a near death experience where God came down and tickled this
little private slip.
Um,
oh my God,
I need an underwear that feels like the hand of God welcoming my balls to the
pearly gates only to say your work is not finished.
So
this isn't what they meant by feel free.
They said to improvise.
Speaking of prints,
it's a segue this v day,
Oh gee,
this v day season me undies.
We'll be releasing a new print every Tuesday.
Oh,
heart shaped like a dick.
How does that work?
That means you and your loved ones can chill and matching prints for v day and
play the game of how long can we keep these on?
Oh my goodness.
Michelle Donesh meshing of cubes.
We'll be back after these messages in down times.
No,
no,
no baby.
The Christmas ones.
I love him.
But why stop at undies this year?
Me undies is launching their v day prince in lounge pants and onesies as well.
Both are made from the same micro modal modal fabrics as their undies.
Me undies has a great offer for my listeners for any first time purchasers.
When you order me undies,
you get 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on to get
your 50 15% off your first pair and free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] by the way,
and yet you're not exactly a,
you Kinda,
you know,
you get what you need to be pretty quick too.
Yeah,
you are definitely in touch with your body.
That's mango mango.
There you go.
Baden other side of the bed.
I'm going asleep basically putting on my Bose headset.
If you listen to those screaming whores,
that's why you can't have kids,
bitch.
Uh,
why you can't keep a man motherfucker dollar shave club.
That's why your dad never call you Mitch.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need.
That's why you walking the street,
bitch.
Um,
what happened?
What happened?
Dollar Shave Club.
What is that?
That's that chick on the fucking subway.
Just kept going.
What happened?
That he fucking the guy with the eight ball jacket and he fucking won on us.
A different woman.
The what happened when was another one?
Okay.
Bobbing head doll.
Shade Club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you never have to go to the store.
Uh,
that's because they delivered everything right to you,
right to your front door.
And they keep you fully stocked on what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club is everything you need to get ready.
No matter what you're getting ready for.
They have you covered.
Head to toe for your hair,
your skin,
your face,
you name it.
They gathered.
Um,
and they have this new program where they automatically keep you stocked up on
products you use.
You determine what you want and when you want it.
And it shows right up at your front door or back door,
whatever you want.
All right.
Throw it right through the window.
If you went from once a month to once every six months plus with their handsome
discount,
the more you buy,
the more you save.
And Right now dollar shave club has a bunch of their status sets.
Uh,
you can try for just $5 like their oral care kit.
After that,
the restock box ships regular sized products at a regular price gets your status
set for just $5.
Do Right now@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's jointly shave club dot dotcom
slash.
[inaudible].
All right,
last one.
Quit.
Q U I p starting a healthy routine and sticking to it are two very different
things.
Inevitably,
we all skimp on that full night of sleep.
Skip a workout or to or brush our teeth with a tired old toothbrush.
We're not perfect,
but we can do better.
And quip is a better electric toothbrush that can help.
Oh,
they're only solving that and that they want to help all the other shit.
I'm going to sleep well and work out and brush my teeth.
Sorry,
Bill.
We're just gonna fix brushing your teeth sensitive sonic vibrations for an
effective clean that's gentle on your sensitive gums.
Geez,
what a women going to use this for.
Brush heads are automatically delivered on a dentist recommended schedule.
Which dentist do I know this guy?
Can I see his credentials every three months for just $5?
Your friendly reminder,
when it's time for a refresh and to stay committed to your own or oral health,
75% of us use old,
worn out bristles that are ineffective.
Quip is one of the most,
is one of the first electric toothbrushes accompanied by the acceptance,
sorry,
by the American Dental Association.
They are backed by over 25,000 dental professionals.
Geez.
You thought being a comedian was fucking competitive.
There's 25,000 there's 25 dental professionals out there who just agree with
this.
They get all the ones that disagreed.
I mean,
you know,
I'm surprised and I'm out there shooting each other like drug dealers and they
have thousands shoot each other with Novocaine.
No,
sorry.
And they have thousands of verified verified five star reviews over 1 million.
Happy,
healthy mouth due to quip starts at just 25 bucks.
And if you go to get quip geet Q u I p.com/burr right now you can get your first
refill pack for free.
That's your first refill pack for
free@geetquip.com slash [inaudible].
There it is.
All right.
And lastly,
but not leastly.
I love when you do the podcast,
Nia,
you know,
thank you.
That's great.
You're funny.
You kill it.
Oh,
it's girlfriend won't lose weight,
dear Billy,
not so fat.
This is from the other day.
Okay.
It's a very delicate situation.
Uh,
yes,
I'm here.
Okay.
My girlfriend and I have been dating for three years going on four and I'm
starting to have different feelings towards her because of her eating habits and
the way she takes care of herself.
Since I met her several years ago,
she had,
she kind of had a weight thing that was noticeable but didn't think anything of
it because I thought she would get on some sort of kick of wanting to lose some
weight in the years to come.
Uh,
well it's been three and a half years and barely making a face over there.
Well,
it's been three and a half years and there's no stopping her from losing weight,
weight,
losing weight.
She's 25 and I'm 30 and I don't know what to do.
She loves to see me gaining weight.
She loves the sweets and is not a fan of running because it hurts her feet.
Help Bill.
I love her,
but I don't want to spend my early thirties miserable in a relationship with
someone who doesn't want to take care of herself.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Now,
what does he say to her?
First of all,
motherfucker,
you fell in love with her when she was a little thick and you were just like,
oh,
so lose weight,
but you still fell for her and now you're mad that the bits is gained weight.
It's like she obviously likes to eat.
You knew that from jump.
So why are you get an extra street on this one motherfucker from the jump
because Shit's off.
Okay,
so,
so what's the problem?
She won't she,
she just keeps gaining weight.
The bitch be getting fat and,
all right.
P H.
A t.
All right.
My in it.
Am I in the club?
No,
you're not in it for a second shot because it makes her feet.
Yeah.
Jogging is terrible for your knees,
so you know,
not everybody fuck going to hurt your feet.
Not everybody likes to jog.
There's other ways,
but I mean,
I don't know.
Don't you think?
Okay,
I'll play devil's advocate here.
All right.
You can't get what you get with somebody and you were at a particular way.
You got to hover in that zone.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can't get reality show fat on him for reality show.
I'm just saying it.
Let me ask you this,
Nick.
At what point,
remember how pasty I am?
Yeah.
All right.
Oh,
I remember
stare at it every day.
My Ba,
I just start looking like a fucking snowman and then suddenly my gut,
when you don't want it,
gets it can't go out anymore and it starts to drop and it starts hanging over
your fucking junk a little bit.
Well,
you know,
I mean you can't tell me you're not going to be like going like,
hey,
uh hey,
they're a Michelin man.
What are you doing over there in person to ask?
Because I've never had a problem with a little extra on a guy.
I haven't ever like thought it was like,
oh he's too fat for me or whatever.
Like crazy obese.
Sure.
That's what I'm saying.
But I'm like,
what's your name on the thicker side?
I don't mind a little thickness to a guy.
I think it's got a nice,
he's not saying that.
I think that's where she started and now on the thick side and now she was
around,
she was a thickie that maybe he could have taken a couple of blue.
Well,
you know,
a couple of laps around the block and he's still got with her and he's been with
her three years since like is she eating by herself?
Nia.
He looked at her the way men,
women look at men a lot of time.
This is a fixer upper and then he bought the house and all of a sudden,
well that's your problem.
I've,
I've always,
I've said it before on this podcast and I'll say it again.
You don't fall in love with potential.
It's a trap.
Alright,
now can you help the guy out?
What am I supposed to say?
Well he always see loves her.
How does he go?
Listen,
Tbi,
you know,
can you fucking lay off the fucking strawberry shortcake here?
Ah,
well maybe,
let's see.
What would I say?
A lead by example and be like,
you know what?
I want to be healthy.
Like I want to cook healthy.
Like I want to exercise more.
Like what do you think?
Do you want to do it with me?
And that can be like a thing.
No,
that's how you doing.
I don't know.
The way to do it is to say,
I think women are too smart.
They'll see through you saying,
I'm fat.
Yeah,
that's true.
If I came up,
you say,
Hey,
I've been thinking about eating some Brussels sprouts.
You want eat some Brussels sprouts with me?
Yeah.
I'd be like,
what the fuck is that supposed to mean?
Yeah.
He's saying,
I'm fat.
You fucking bald red cunt.
That's what it would come out of your mouth.
This guy obviously,
yeah.
Wants to be with this person,
right.
It's top.
He'd see he writes it a little bit fun.
Funny.
Yeah,
but read that last part again.
I love her,
but like say that again.
Read that last part.
Okay.
I love her,
but I don't want to spend my early thirties miserable in a relationship with
someone who doesn't want to take care of herself.
Yeah.
This is his fucking thing about people being fat fucks now and being proud of
it.
It's like you're killing yourself.
You're gonna die.
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
You're not a doctor.
You can't say that.
You don't know what,
like how I am not a doctor,
but I can say that and I just did and I can say that because that's like me
saying that you smoking cigarettes,
you're going to get lung cancer.
You're not a doctor.
I can't say that.
Oh yeah,
no,
of course.
But like sometimes just the way your body looks doesn't determine your level of
health.
Does she not work out at all?
That's what he's saying.
Hmm.
She's sitting there and she's eating and she's getting fatter and fatter.
That's not fair to the other person there.
I know,
but you know what?
Sometimes it's not about the other person.
Sometimes you're going through something.
Sometimes you just want to fuck a fucking two years.
Sometimes you don't want to think about dieting and exercising all the time and
being caught in that circle of constantly like,
I need to die.
I need to exercise.
I need to die today.
I'd like
to learn how to eat well.
Maybe that's not something that she feels like doing right now.
I feel like I'm talking about myself because I want to lose weight.
I'm trying to lose this baby weight,
but like I just sometimes I just don't want,
this isn't about you.
It's about this person.
Yes.
Self centered.
I feel like in demand
because I don't feel like necessarily being on that goddamn hamster wheel.
I want to go back to my trainer.
Now that I have recovered from my hernia surgery,
I'm going to get back into it,
but like to think about eating healthy all the time and exercising all the time.
Like sometimes you just don't fucking want to,
are you going to dump me?
Are you going to like kick me to the curb?
You do.
You realize how fucking insane you are right now.
This was literally about another woman and you're fucking yelling at me like I
said it.
I'm trying to help this kid out so he can,
he loves this woman and you know it.
It's a good thing to lose weight.
It's not good for you.
Every five,
every pound of fat is a hundred miles of capillary.
Somebody told me that one time.
So every time your heart beats.
Oh yes.
I don't remember,
but
somebody told me no,
but the thing is is you put that weight on this,
there's more mass.
Your body has to grow more capillaries,
so cause that party would die.
It needs oxygen.
Oxygenated blood.
I can't even say it right.
Oxygenate oxygen.
That's a tough one.
Oxygenated.
Oh God,
we had a kid.
Ox.
Wow.
Hopefully she'll be smarter than us.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can't just say it has to grow that.
So then that's an extra like,
you know,
it's like a paper route.
There's an extra five customers every day.
Nobody wants to be overweight.
Okay.
Everybody wants to be in shape.
Everybody wants to look.
Can you,
can you remove yourself?
I can't.
It's crumbling.
It's close to home.
It's,
it's hitting close to home.
Okay.
Fair enough.
All right.
Well you know what buddy?
I tried you.
What would you do?
I would buy a Ukulele and I would write a silly song about how she needs to get
in shape
and I would say that my Dick wrote it so they wouldn't be mad at me
seriously though.
I would tell him that.
Listen,
I never told this before.
Uh,
no,
because when I go down on you now,
I'm starting to get claustrophobic because I feel like the walls are closing in
from both sides and from above,
and I just,
wow.
I feel like it can't breathe.
Is there a way?
No,
I don't know what I would say.
It's a tough one.
That's a tough one to answer.
So you're beautiful.
I love you.
But if you don't hit the treadmill,
I'm going to buy a human leash and start dragging around the block.
I don't know.
Do you want to do this yoga class with me after work?
We could do couple's
yoga together.
What?
I feel like you have to,
if you're going to,
oh,
that's what you said.
I think you asked me if I'm gonna go fucking Yoga class.
We've been to yoga class together.
But you have to.
I think if you're,
if you're really concerned about though,
seriously,
you should suggest that you do stuff that's healthy together.
Like let's cook meals together.
Let's go to yoga class.
I actually think like that's,
that's,
I feel like that's the nicest way to do it without making the person feel like
you're singling them out or you know why I think she put on yourself say,
listen,
I want to get into really good shape.
I feel like I'm,
I'm not in the shape I want to be in.
Uh,
and I was,
you know,
when I used to be in better shape before I met you just make that shit up.
Cause I used to go to the gym with a buddy of mine.
Now she's going to see through all of this.
Yeah.
You gotta it's gotta be like,
Hey,
you want to make dinner together?
Do you want to go to your other classes
together?
Just nice and easy.
I am like the way you make me some healthy smoothies every morning.
Something like that.
Cause I appreciate it.
Does healthy smoothies?
Okay,
well you know what,
this,
this was a tough one.
That's one of the hardest ones that,
hey ladies,
any ladies out there,
um,
right in,
and how can a guy,
or how would you tell how,
yeah,
how can a man tell a woman,
you know,
that he loves,
he wants to stay with her but she's putting on fucking weight,
you know,
and it's,
he's,
he's helping her out near I know,
but he didn't fall in love with like her body obviously.
Like he fell in love with something else about her.
Yeah.
You can't say that.
Look,
if you fell in love with the guy and then he puts on weight and he's his pot
smoking fucking guy.
Where like to this ways that women can fall out of love with the guy that they
fell in love with because he's letting himself go because he stopped going after
it because he's partying too much.
There's all the same and,
and putting on weight is in that.
Okay.
Like someone like to fall in love with someone and then a couple of years later
are like literally twice the size that they are.
That's isn't that,
that's selfish behavior,
but,
no,
but the thing is I don't feel like it's necessarily selfish what else is going
on in their life?
Because maybe there's something that's leading to that extra eating or stress
eating or whatever.
Maybe there's something else going on.
Can anybody just be a lazy fuck and they just eaten fucking Sundays?
Why does it always have to be like,
I get touched funny by my mailman.
So now I use fucking Coco Crisp to be a good human being and seeing beyond the
superficial and to see what's in someone's heart and mind.
You know what?
This probably right.
My thing is Iowa,
I bury everything.
So I just get up like a fucking robot.
I mean,
it's working for me,
but I understand.
I don't know.
I had,
well,
you know what I accomplished?
I accomplished how difficult.
This is such a difficult thing to talk about,
you know,
and uh,
hmm.
Bitches be getting fat.
I don't know what to tell you.
I'm joking.
I'm all right.
There you go.
Near.
I think you look beautiful.
I've been trying to bang you for like a fucking,
since I came back from Europe,
you know,
we tried all my smooth lines,
like,
can you do something about this over here?
Uh,
I bought a little Atta boy over here.
Even grabbing me in restaurants and things like that.
Yeah.
Even manhandling me even coming up behind me in the kitchen,
that type of thing.
Yup.
I'll give it to you.
Okay.
Then tell me a favor.
You know,
don't,
don't put yourself out.
All right?
You know,
find it in your fucking heart.
Why?
According to you,
I don't do anything.
I just,
apparently I just lie there and just take it and don't participate.
I believe you cue shit on me first.
What do you ma'am,
you criticize my performance first.
I got defensive and I say that you're a fucking animal in bed.
I never said that you weren't.
All right.
Well there you go.
We'll stop back in.
Like,
I'm not fucking doing something for you.
You are doing,
you're doing a lot for me.
Don't laugh.
We right now have you.
Oh,
Nia.
You know something else.
You know what,
you're not as complex as you like to act.
Okay.
You don't think I'm running around in there,
but I'm in there.
I'm between those years.
Wow.
Yeah.
Great comeback.
That's it.
Alright.
Jerk face.
Uh,
thanks for hanging out with me.
this or having me.
Oh,
we got to bring up William Stephenson.
a sad thing here.
After all the laughs,
uh,
another great comic and other great friends and just somebody who like I must've
done,
I feel like I did a million shows with William Stephenson.
Unfortunately he passed away.
Uh,
I believe it was on Monday of this week.
And um,
I'm gonna miss that guy.
I just,
yeah,
we used to have so many running jokes cause we always used to do late night
shows in New York City and I remember that stupid Mcdonald's thing came up by
that pop up.
I'm loving it and we would just come in and every time we would sing something
different by that Bup,
bup,
Ba,
I'm fucking it.
Or just something stupid and it would just always make us laugh.
We would always do it on like the third show when it was like half the fucking
room was full.
And um,
you know what,
I got to find it.
I have a great picture of me and him back when I had hair and Greg Geraldo.
Yeah.
Um,
it's probably sad photo.
I guess I'm next on that photo.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
Well,
it's how it works in the Ed,
you know,
it's like a forest fire.
Okay.
You burned down a redhead and all sudden some brunettes grow.
Um,
all right,
so rest in peace.
William,
you're one of the greats and uh,
definitely gonna miss you and thank you to the comedy cellar and all those clubs
that I got to work with them in.
Um,
he was just,
he was the best host and I used to host the shows.
He was the fucking best and I never heard him say a bad word about anybody,
so,
and he was a hell of a musician to play the piano.
I didn't know that.
Oh Man.
You got to know him when he was a guest on tough crowd quite a few times.
He used to do,
but I didn't know that he played music too.
Oh yeah.
He used,
Jeff Ross used to go on stage with them and he would play this really cool,
perfect accompaniment music when Jeff used to do his poems.
Right,
right.
You know,
and he,
and we just,
it worked great.
And they had so much fun together on stage,
which is I got to be,
honestly,
when I was watching bumping Mike's with,
um,
with Jeff and Dave Attell,
it reminded me of that and I got to tell you,
there's something about,
I don't know,
there was something about that to comics going on stage,
watching them have fun and you end up seeing,
they see like,
I've never seen Dave like smile as much as that.
It's,
it's been great to watch.
So anyways,
rest in peace.
Uh,
William Stephenson,
another great comic gone.
Um,
so anyways,
that's,
that's the podcast.
You guys have a great weekend.
Enjoy the music.
Yeah,
there'll be another half hour of a greatest hit Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
The fall is another 30 minutes.
All right.
That's it.
Hit the treadmill.
You son of bitches.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
Emma Bombay
[inaudible] miles.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 17th,
2011 that I'm actually doing Tuesday morning,
Tuesday fucking morning.
And I know why a lot of you think I am.
You probably thought I was grieving for an extra 24 hours because the patriots
lost to the fucking hated green current jets.
Um,
actually no,
I was in Atlantic city.
I was in Atlantic City and uh,
you know,
I didn't bring the podcast all the fucking equipment back.
I came into New York on fucking Tuesday.
I didn't want to be lugging that shit around and then lug it down there and uh,
like an asshole.
I didn't realize I had a six o'clock in the evening flight.
Um,
I'm kind of famous for that.
I never know when my flights leave.
I'm always like,
Yay,
I think I leave around 10:00 AM and then I find out it's 6:00 AM as I'm sitting
at a bar drinking at three in the morning.
And then I go,
oh fuck.
Well,
there's no reason to go to bed now.
Is there,
um,
any ways.
So let's,
uh,
let's get down to brass fucking tax here.
Uh,
this is going to kill me.
Um,
out of all the podcasts that I've done for the last,
I'm just loving how excited the jets fans are right now.
I know this sitting there with their fucking ear cups right up to the Goddamn
speaker.
Probably giving their fucking boss the finger.
Fuck you motherfucker.
I was waiting all season for this.
There's a big fucking crow laying on his plate and I'm going to watch your meet
every Goddamn fucking bite and the feathers.
Um,
yeah.
Out of all the podcasts I've had to do,
this is,
this is going to be one of the toughest ones,
toughest things I've ever going to have to say.
Congratulations to the New York jets,
their organization of their fans.
You fucking deserved it.
You went up there,
you were talking shit,
and you're fucking won the game.
And,
uh,
and that's,
that's it.
You won it.
You won the fucking game.
And,
uh,
this is what I think happened,
during the game.
I thought both teams came out.
There was so much fucking hype before that game.
And uh,
I as always was nervous.
A nervous Nelly all week,
you know,
is from my,
as much shit as I talk about the Jetson Shit.
If you notice when they play the Patriots,
I never claimed that we're going to win.
Remember that?
Remember when the 45 to three game,
remember that before and I was going,
eh,
got a bed.
I got a bad feeling,
man.
That's from being a Boston sports fan,
pre winning championships.
I just always,
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm waiting for the misery.
Um,
and I was getting into,
and this is another thing that I didn't like,
I didn't like that everyone was saying the Patriots were going to win.
And everyone was saying that I got to the airport,
you know,
this is me going in New York.
You go to the airport patriots,
uh,
or on the cover of sports illustrated.
And I know people go,
oh,
the fucking Jake's,
you know,
the sports illustrated jinx.
You ever think that maybe they just don't know how to pick a winner.
You ever think maybe that maybe that's their fucking problem.
Um,
I saw that and then I was watching a little bit.
Espn you only thing I liked was the jets were talking shit.
And I was like,
I hope they keep doing this,
just keep doing this.
And I hope they get off the plane wearing fatigues like the fucking Miami
hurricanes.
Um,
that's what I was hoping.
But uh,
I was talking to Versie my gambling buddy and he was putting money on the
Patriots and when he saw,
uh,
when rex Ryan said,
you know,
it's going to be me,
verse Belicheck,
he texted me and was going through it.
It's over.
Why would he do that?
That's the dumbest fucking thing to say.
But Baba Baba,
Baba and a,
I don't know,
you guys won't believe me if I tell you the whole week I was going look to our
defense and I've been saying that all fucking year and he's gone now.
Yeah.
Again,
it's just like the giants when the giants went on their fucking run.
No,
it isn't.
It isn't.
And then he said something else.
He goes,
well,
don't worry.
I go do we let up like 24 to 26 points of fucking game for two thirds of the
season.
We start in four fucking rookies.
And he goes,
yeah,
but dude,
don't you score like 35 points a game and that that's when my fucking by heart
sank into my stomach.
And I was like wow.
He just described Dan Marino's career.
How are we going to win the Superbowl?
We don't have a defense.
Adot worry.
We got Marino.
Hey Daddy,
why don't you go out and score 40 today?
That only works in the regular season.
So
I was like,
look,
all they got to do,
if they establish the rod we're fucked because they're going to chew up the
clock and then Brady is not going to be on the field.
He can't hurt you if he's not in the field.
So that's what I was worried about.
I was hoping we were going to rate the jets but I was worried that if they got
their running game going,
if lt started fucking running,
we were going to be in trouble.
Okay.
Cause I didn't buy into the fucking hype where it's like,
wow,
this is what we did the last time.
Yeah.
But the time before we lost,
all right,
central,
we lost 28 to 14,
five fucking years ago.
We lost like four months ago.
So I just is what,
and this is honestly my heart of hearts.
What I think happened,
the Patriots came out and they picked up right where they let off.
And then Brady threw arguably the worst pass of his career.
And I think the Patriots just got spooked.
They got,
they was stunned and then the jet got run the ball down right down to like what?
Like the 12 yard line.
And then they came out like the fucking keystone cops.
That first series.
Sanchez goes to hand off the ball and he trips is fucking running back.
Then they ran a a fucking,
uh,
I block so much of this game up because of the pain of watching the Patriots
lose,
but some sort of sweep and whoever was running it,
fake somebody out and then bumped into his own Lyman and then they missed the
field goal.
And I was like,
all right,
the jets are tight,
they're fucking nervous.
And then the patriots.
Kay.
And I really think though,
because Brady had not fucked up since October,
I think because of the hype of the game,
they were like,
oh fuck,
not now,
not to this team.
And for the rest of the game they were pressing and they went right down on the
fucking field.
He throws a touchdown pass in,
the guy drops it,
they get a field goal and then I just feel like the rest of the game they were
playing in panic mode.
Like they were up three to nothing and they were playing.
Well,
our defense sucks that they just,
it sucks.
Um,
but like the offense would come out and then the jets went up seven to three and
the patriots come out like they're down 28 to three.
I just felt they never got into the rhythm.
A lot of it was because of the jets had a monster fucking,
uh,
pass rush.
But I just,
I just was like,
you know,
they,
they fucking call the fake punt UK foot.
She dropped a touchdown pass.
You dropped the fake punt,
you throw a first down to Deon branch and he fucking drops it.
It was like they,
they would just,
I just don't think they up.
They needed to go down on that first drive in score a touchdown in.
The last thing they needed was Brady to throw a pic and they just never got go.
We got going for half a second when we scored that touchdown and had the two
point conversion and it was 14 to 11 and then,
uh,
then we had the momentum.
We are great.
And we fucking nailed the guy on the kickoff.
And I'm like,
okay,
our defense has to pull one out of their ass here and fucking Clampton down and
we have to get the ball back.
And it was a moment in the fee that was the moment in the game and fucking Mark
Trent Dilfer Sanchez throws a fucking eight yard pass that turns into a 70 yard
fucking game.
And that,
that for me,
that was fucking,
that was it.
That was it.
Even though we scored that touchdown in the end.
Uh,
it just,
it just wasn't our fucking day.
Even we do onside kicks in,
the fucking ball seemed to be laying there for x eight seconds and we were
running around.
Where is it?
I don't see a jet with it.
I can't find it.
Um,
anyways,
but congratulations to the jets,
man.
You know,
you gotta hand it to them,
do it.
They talked shit and they came in and they fucking want,
but I gotta be honest.
It wasn't as amazing is everybody's making it out to be the same way.
The Patriots are not as amazing as they were made out to be going into this
fucking game.
And it's why I don't watch ESPN and I don't,
uh,
I watched the gay,
I had the game on mute because I knew the game was going to take seven years off
my life unless it went like that 45 to three game,
which to be honest,
jet fans,
I was still nervous when we were up like 28 to nothing.
That's how bad our fucking difference was on that game.
But like,
I don't,
I don't know,
I guess because they're trying to get ratings,
but I don't get how you go one and one during the regular season and then
whatever you did the last time,
you try to act like that's who the fuck you are.
And that's who the other guy is.
Or like the jets,
like there's nothing to,
I've got to let emails from,
from jet fans.
This one guy goes,
the dynasty is over.
And um,
it's like,
dude,
we haven't won a Superbowl since 2004.
It's been over for seven fucking years.
The dynasty ended when Teddy Bruschi had that,
that fucking mild stroke or seizure or whatever he had.
That was the end of it.
And then we,
you know,
we lost a few guys.
We were never quite the same.
But the thing is that's been the same has been Belichick and Brady.
So people are acting like they're beating the Superbowl team.
This is the team that got by the Ravens last year,
first round of the fucking playoffs.
And uh,
you know,
so I don't know.
So whatever,
congratulations.
I still have yet to be proven wrong about the jet Stowe.
Okay.
If you guys remember,
because people forget what I said.
They said they were going to win the fucking super bowl and they talked all this
fucking shit.
All they have achieved at this point is getting back to the game that they lost
last year.
So,
uh,
but you know,
whatever my teams out of it,
so I'm done being a cunt.
So whatever good luck jet fans,
you've got a 42 year monkey on your back.
Uh,
I know what that's like times two plus fucking,
uh,
four years,
two years,
whatever it was,
86,
86 fucking years.
So,
uh,
good luck to you.
This is the thing,
I this,
let me give you the backstory.
I was watching this game by myself at the Borgata in Atlantic city,
um,
by myself with the mute on,
on the game because I can't,
when games are that big,
I can handle any sort of comment that I consider more ironic.
Cause at one point Deon branch caught a ball and he was all amped up and he was
yelling over the jet sidelines and I on hit mute and I hear Phil sims going Deon
branch and he's yelling at Rex Ryan.
I don't know why he'd be doing that.
Yeah,
why would he,
why would he yell at that guy who's been talking shit saying that the Brady,
the Brady,
that the Patriots are in a good team and people on their team of call and Brady
and asshole.
Yeah.
Why do you think there would be some sort of chat or Phil Sims?
Did you play your entire career with the Bose headphones on?
You fucking ah,
drove me nuts.
So I had fucking hit mute.
I had to hit mute and uh,
yeah.
Ugh.
It was fucking brutal.
And I was,
and I texted Versie at halftime.
This was another turning point at halftime.
Okay.
First of all,
what the fuck?
We gave the Goddamn jets,
the ball on our own,
48 or 30 yard line four fucking times.
And the first half,
the fact that we weren't down like 28 to three at the half was a minor miracle
and the defense actually was stepping up in that half.
But you know,
I knew it was going to come down to the fucking defense because I know a lot of
Patriot fans think it was the fucking offense.
But the offense is entitled to have a bad day to struggle every once in a
fucking blue moon.
Okay.
That's when the defense has to step it up.
And we just did not have a defense that could do that.
Okay.
If the defense could have stepped it up and got some three and outs,
Brady in them,
they would have got into a rhythm.
We just couldn't get into a fucking rhythm because our defense has been like
room temperature butter all fucking year.
Um,
so anyways,
when we got that personal foul call,
that undisciplined play that like the San Diego chargers would back in the day,
I was just like,
I was,
I,
I hate to say it,
I was like,
this fucking game is over.
You know,
I still watched,
cause I can't bail on my fucking team.
I still watch,
but I was just like,
this fucking game is over.
Like they have completely Ben rattled by the jets.
They're completely out of their fucking game plan and their playing
like I'd like an inexperienced fucking team.
Um,
and I texted Paul Versey and I wrote,
I fuckin and then a capital letters told you we had this big debate was working
down the comedy cellar Friday and I get ready for my big shows with David Tell
Jim Breuer and Jim and Jim Norton down at the Borgata.
So I didn't want to be the weak link on that fucking gigantic comedy show.
So I was uh,
stealing my shit around the city and Virginia gave me a ride home and he was
gone,
dude,
it's going to be a blood bath.
I'm telling you,
it's gonna be a fucking bloodbath.
And I was going,
Paul,
our defense sucks.
All they gotta do is run the ball.
But that,
that,
you know what's funny is that didn't even need neither thing that we said
happened.
I thought the jets are really going to establish the fucking run and chew up the
clock.
That's what I thought was going to happen.
And no way,
shape or form that.
I think Tom Brady was going to have that bad of a game.
I mean,
dude,
they were fucking off.
Did you see that one play where Grankowski he's running a go pattern and Brady
throws an out.
It was just like,
what?
What the fuck is going?
They were completely rattled and I don't know if it,
I think it was the interception slash all the shit talk in the jets were doing.
I think that they wanted to beat him that fucking bad.
That when he fucked up.
MMM.
With that fucking Jesus Christ.
I mean that,
that,
that thing was like a,
if rex Grossman made us instructional video
on how to throw whatever that pass was,
it wasn't a fucking a screen pass.
I don't know what it was.
It was just a,
Oh my God.
It was just like,
I'm already picked it off and I was like,
oh no.
Oh No.
Not now.
Not this week.
Not to this fucking team.
So I have to go down.
This is the funny thing.
This is the funniest thing about all of this.
I've talked so much shit about the jets this year.
Last week,
the jets lose to the fucking colts yet when the fucking game,
which is why I think the cult,
the jets could win because when you win a championship,
not only are you good,
but you have that stepped in.
Shit luck.
The tuck rule.
What the fuck was that?
Right.
All right,
fuck it.
Give us the ball back.
Yay.
We win the helmet.
Catch you just,
and with the jets you have the colts calling timeout with 29 seconds left.
You know,
just in case we get the ball back with a 5.5 seconds left a tip,
we'll call the time out here and have mediocre Mark Sanchez with the fucking
deer in the headlights.
Give them a nice minute to chill out.
Gather his thought,
give rex an opportunity to give them the next three plays so he can show out.
Next play.
18 yard completion game over.
Um,
you gotta have that stepped in.
Shit.
Look.
And I just feel like,
I feel like the jets have that.
They have that,
uh,
oh my God,
we're gonna lose this game.
And then somebody hits somebody out of bounds for no fucking reason.
Oh,
wait a minute.
We just got a first down.
So
I don't know.
This should be a great fucking game this week.
All right.
And I love being a jet hater.
I love that the jets beat Pittsburgh the last time and that the game is in
Pittsburgh and that Polamalu is playing this week.
And uh,
and I love that ESPN will probably hype the shit out of the jets.
That's what I'm hoping.
Um,
so anyway,
so I'm sitting there,
let's get to the misery now.
The misery of my fucking life that day.
Some sitting there,
okay.
On one of the most unbelievable fucking weekends I've ever done in comedy.
Like I got to work with Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer and David tell myself we were all on the same show at the Borgata.
We played at 2100 seater or 20,
whatever,
the fucking big one.
And we sold it out three fucking times.
And I was just sitting there thinking like,
how fucking him it,
first of all,
I had not seen Jim,
let's,
let's go through the lineup here.
I had not seen Jim Norton do stand up a headlining set
since before the OPN,
Anthony virus tours.
That's how fucking long it's been because me and him came up together.
So when I started headlining,
he started headlining at a,
he actually blew up,
uh,
before most of us from our,
our graduating class,
he got on the European Anthony Show,
um,
pre that whole scandal in the church.
He was already headlining.
So I never got to really,
I never got to work with them.
So he was,
he opened the show so,
and I,
and I was going on next.
So I got to stand there every fucking night watching him work,
watching him switch some jokes around and the absolutely killing.
He was fucking hilarious.
He's got this bit on,
uh,
that new show.
Hoarders that fucking killed me every night.
And uh,
it was,
it was fucking awesome.
Cause you know,
I do the road.
I do it.
You know,
when I go out,
I go with the roads,
I go with [inaudible] but I,
I don't get to work with any of my peers,
like the guys that I started out with anymore.
And then on top of that,
then I had brewer and a tell and those were the guys when I came down from
Boston and I was this fucking nerd,
new comic and I'd be in the back of the Boston comedy club with like my
backpack.
I swear to God I had a backpack.
Right.
Cause I would walk around,
you know,
on the subway and I had all my shit in there.
My comedy notebook,
you know,
just in case comedy inspiration at me,
I was a total fucking nerd and I used to sit at the back of the Boston Comedy
Club,
which they should make a fucking movie about that place.
It was the rise,
most intimidating fucking room I ever went into.
Um,
I mean in a lot of ways it was worse.
I did the Apollo one time,
it was worse than that.
Um,
cause he,
Apollo,
there's this odd sort of no pressure because you're expecting to get booed.
He still,
you don't want to get booed,
but if he get booed,
I mean the amount of p they booed.
Like Lauryn Hill,
like famous superstars have gotten boots so it's not that bad.
But like,
uh,
the way the Boston Comedy Club was run back in the day was completely opposite
to all the other comedy clubs that I made,
at least in my experience.
Like this is how they would do it.
They would,
uh,
you know,
if you came down and you were a new comic and they were going to put you on,
they put you on early in the show and they tried to,
uh,
you know,
assess where you were as a comedian by sticking you basically in the show where
they figured your talents we're at,
which is,
you know,
if you're newer,
they put you earlier in the show,
the Boston Comedy Club,
if you came down,
they're like,
oh yeah,
you're a new comic.
You want to go on,
all right.
They put you on like three quarters through the show after like fucking Louis Ck
,
Jim Breuer,
Jay Moore had just leveled the fucking room and then you,
they right,
you want to go on next,
right.
And you literally would feel like,
you know those spike Lee movies where the,
where the main character that he be focusing on is just standing there.
But the background is like slowly pulling away.
That's,
that's what I would feel like.
And I would immediately go from,
you know,
feeling like,
five foot 10 to feeling like I was like three,
four,
10 I and I,
it was fucking unbelievable.
I was the worst.
And then all comics hung out in the back and you were convinced that they all
thought you sucked and they were all watching you.
It was brutal.
So anyway,
so I got to work with those guys this weekend and I'm,
I'm sitting there like a fan all weekend and the crowds were amazing and a,
but the whole weekend is fucking jets.
Patriots game is looming and I'm sitting here going,
this fucking game can go either goddamn way they want.
Once we won once,
I don't know what the fuck everybody's talking about.
Like this is going to be a cake walk our defense.
All right?
And I'm just sitting there at one point,
who was actually last week when the jets beat the colts.
I'm sitting there going like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
I'm literally to the comedy guts going,
what are the fucking odds that the team I've been talking shit about for the
entire fucking year.
He's not only
gonna make the playoffs back into the fucking playoffs,
lose a playoff game,
but then fucking win the fucking thing.
The next week they're going to play my fucking team.
Alright?
And I'm going to be in New Jersey.
The fucking game is at four o'clock or four 30 whatever the fuck it is.
And I go on stage at eight in New Jersey,
in front of a bunch of fucking jet fans.
Why does this keep happening to me?
It's unfucking.
I can't,
I can't explain it.
I go down to Philly,
all that fucking shit out.
I guess that it had nothing to do about sports.
Sports pulled me out of the mud down there.
Another fucking time.
I have a random weekend booked at Caroline's,
a random fucking weekend.
They book it like six,
seven,
eight months out.
And Lo and behold,
the weekend I come in,
the first night I come in,
the night I fly in to do morning press.
I flew in on like a fucking Thursday or Wednesday,
I can't remember what the fucking Yankees won the world series.
And I'm staying in Times Square.
I'm trying to sleep and I can't cause all I hear is out in the fucking outside
my hotel window.
[inaudible]
and I'm sitting there with pillows on each fucking head.
So now
sitting there and I'm going,
this is classic,
my career.
This is either going to be fucking amazing or an absolute goddamn debacle.
And I was sitting in my fucking hotel room and Brady threw that pick and I was
like,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
please.
No,
please,
please don't.
Not this week for the love of fucking God kitchen.
Not I'm trying to go a hundred days without boozing canyon,
not do with this week.
I know we're not good enough to win the super bowl this fucking year.
I know we're going to lose in the playoffs,
but can we just not lose to these fucking shit talking cunts please.
Right.
And then they fucking keystone cop did and missed the field goal and we drove
down there and I ended it just,
it just,
it just fucking unraveled.
And the whole time I'm sitting there going,
what is going to happen at my standup show?
What?
Cause I already had been walking around the casino that day and all I'm seeing
is jets jerseys.
I see a couple of,
I'm in fucking Atlantic City,
New Jersey.
Yeah.
All right.
The Eagles are not in the playoffs.
There's no playoffs,
there's no eagles fans there.
It's jets fans.
And I get this show to fucking do and I perform in an art where it's okay to
yell at you,
fucking suck you faggot.
It's okay to do that.
And I'm watching my team on ravel and I'm just sitting there ironing my show
shirt.
Okay,
go.
And not only do I gotta do a podcast and eat fucking crow,
I now have to go down a dance like a fucking monkey for a bunch of Goddamn
elated jet fans who are,
who are probably going to be yelling j e t as jets,
jets,
jets.
Every time I'm trying to do a punchline,
why does this keep happening to me?
Why couldn't I bet in fucking Ohio?
All right,
so now it's seven 30,
the game is basically fucking over.
And then there's a knock on the door at security to bring me downstairs,
which is absolutely fucking hilarious.
Like,
you know,
like I need that,
but you know,
I'll feed my fucking ego and the door opens up.
And I was just like,
I fucking knew it.
I fucking called it that fucking Versie.
He can't,
he's not answering his fucking phone.
I fucking told him,
I fucking told him I knew this was going to fucking happen.
Right.
And,
uh,
the guy takes me downstairs and I'm thinking,
well,
you know what's great about this shit is they're taken me the good fellas way so
I can go down in the elevator,
I'm in the catacombs behind the fucking massive theater.
I'll just sit there.
I'll watch the final fucking minutes of the game,
you know,
because unlike those other fucking fairweather con fans who left Gillette
Stadium,
you know,
I'll get to that later.
But there's a reason why they build stadiums as big as they do.
It's for all the fairweather fucking fans.
All right?
And it's also why you should never be upset if somebody you love does it.
Return of a fucking fan letter,
because that's what fans are.
That's what they are,
you know,
entertain me.
I love you as long you should do what I want and then you don't,
when you're down,
I'm going to walk out on you.
And I'm guilty of it too.
I've had plenty of fucking people that I've been fans of that went broke.
I never sent him any goddamn money.
I just,
I just talked to my friend,
do what the fuck happened and what happened to Leif Garrett
Leaf,
Gary.
So anyway,
so I'm going down into the,
uh,
Indiana.
I'm thinking,
well,
whatever,
I,
you know what,
what the fuck?
There's no way it's going to be worse than Philly.
Um,
I just got to address it the second I go out there,
right.
So,
but at least I can just have this moment of peace,
it fucking deal with the fact that what I kind of knew was gonna happen was
gonna happen.
I just didn't want it to happen to the jets.
So I'm fucking decompressing from that loss.
I got set it aside,
cause now I have to go fucking out there and be dance like a goddamn clown.
So as I'm sitting there watching the final fucking seconds of it,
all of a sudden I hear Jim brewer coming down the fucking Corda going,
you fucking believe this shit.
You fucking,
it just keeps getting louder.
I'm like,
please don't walk into my dressing room.
And he just comes walking in.
He's like,
the fucking Patriot did.
He starts miming jerking off in my face and he goes like,
he just blew a load in my face.
Right?
He goes,
fuck you mother fucker.
Like I had been talking shit all we got
good.
It proceeds to start trashing me in the Patriots and it was actually fucking
hilarious because I saw in him,
I saw me last year screaming about Peyton manning cause you only hear shit about
your team.
You know,
you never hear anything fair and balanced and he's sitting there,
so that's good.
Oh two of Brady,
he's the greatest fucking quarterback ever.
It was literally
my rent from last year about Peyton manning.
So,
ah,
was I getting my just desserts and I,
he just kept trashing me and then I said like,
I'll fuck you.
You still haven't won one since 1969.
He goes,
fuck you,
you sound like a Yankee Fan faggot.
And he's like,
I took a pounding from him.
Um,
classic jet Fan though.
Didn't say shit before the game was all fucking nervous,
just like every was,
everybody was admitted.
I didn't get any emails from jet fans and afterwards,
you know what,
only got a few and it was from the usual cunty ones that uh,
you know,
really need to go hug their dad or whatever.
So then I'm sitting there going,
oh my God.
And a Norton came in and he was kind of fucking laugh.
And he goes,
you're bummed out.
I go,
yeah,
I got them.
I know I'm past it,
dude.
I got to do this.
And I go,
I guys give me a lot of jets fans out there.
Isn't there?
Okay.
Why,
why comedy gods?
Why did I have to be in Atlantic city?
Why did I have to be working with Jim Brewer as much as I fucking love the guy,
why did I have to work be working with the Jet Fan?
You know why?
Because I deserved it because I've been talking shit all fucking year.
I actually became what?
I didn't want to be what I was trashing Rex Ryan for.
So anyway,
so now I'm,
I'm standing out in the waste 20 fucking 100 people.
So I'm peeking through the curtain,
right?
Like some fucking open miker who's never been on stage before.
I look in the front row and what do I see?
I see like five jet jerseys,
some fat fuck with the jets hat and unless got,
Ugh,
God,
Oh God,
here we go.
Here we go.
God dammit.
Ah,
if I could clone myself right now and put a fucking Goddamn,
I'm doing standup sport coat on this person,
I would.
Yeah.
So Jimmy goes out there
in all week.
He just kept,
he just getting funnier.
It was,
it was really fucking awesome watching him.
Ed,
he actually took one joke that was killing in the,
uh,
the end of a set.
He put it at the beginning and it fucking just destroyed.
And then he's just murder up.
Then he murdered him twice Saturday night,
but his clearly just fuck it.
Take it to another level and I'm just laughing,
going,
and Jimmy's going to have a set where I can't even follow them.
Really.
Comedy Gods.
This is really gonna fucking happen.
And uh,
I'm sitting there and then this is okay for all you comedians out there.
I was like,
all right,
what do I got to do?
What?
Well,
how am I going to get out of this?
What is,
what is the,
I can't just go out there and start doing my fucking act
and act like nothing's happening.
I was thinking of going out there and the second they started yelling about the
jets,
I was going to be like,
no,
no.
I'm taping the game.
Don't tell me what happens.
They'll tell me what happened,
but that would be funny for like three fucking seconds.
So I finally,
I was just going like what I always do whenever I,
before I'm going out on stage and I just don't feel like I'm going to have a
good set and I don't feel like I'm funny.
I just said,
what am I feeling?
What am I thinking?
Yeah,
I am thinking,
fuck.
I can't believe the patriots lost and evolve fucking states that I have to be in
to watch them lose to the team that I hate the most right now.
Why did I have to be in New Jersey?
And I was literally like,
Oh,
there's your opener.
That is your opener.
And that's what I went out to.
And all the jets fans would die in fucking laughing and then they left me alone.
They didn't give a fuck.
They will fucking elated.
And uh,
although I couldn't,
I couldn't slow down at any point during my set.
Like the crowds are so great all weekend.
Usually when you have a crowd that big,
you can't really bring them down to try to build it back up again.
You have to kind of just killed the whole time.
I noticed you could bring him down,
which was so great the whole week.
But,
but during that set,
every time I would bring it down,
that would always be one guy.
Yeah.
Fucking jets.
So,
so I took my pounding,
so there you go.
Congratulations.
Seriously.
And I got to,
I have to,
I have to admit something to,
I walked by like,
you know when your team fucking loses a game like this,
will you give a fuck like this?
You cannot watch ESPN for a good three days.
And I haven't been able to do that a lot this year.
I couldn't do it when the Ravens raped us.
I guess it was a year ago when the ravens raped us last year in the playoffs.
Playoffs.
I didn't watch it for like three fucking days.
Um,
when the Lakers beat us in game seven,
you know,
when,
uh,
their,
their 12th man came off the bench with those striped shirts,
it just started fucking call and files and technical files and all that shit.
I'll never get over that by the way.
Um,
I didn't watch it for like fucking four.
I couldn't eat,
I couldn't even watch TV cause I live in Los Angeles.
I had close the windows,
Lakers Faulker had to deal with that.
Um,
and then this one,
I've had three bad things come in threes,
right?
People I don't believe in that either.
You just,
you just start recounting after three.
Um,
and this is one of them.
I just,
I just could not watch it.
I still have not watched one second of ESPN.
I flipped by real quick with,
with the,
with the mute button on.
And if there's a game on,
I'll watch the game.
Um,
but I walked by a TV and I saw Rex Ryan doing the press conference.
I only heard a couple things he had,
but he had a genuine look of joy on his face.
And for half a second,
I was actually somewhere in my jet Hayden mind happy for the guy like Ah,
the motherfucker,
he did it and he fucking did it.
That son of a bitch,
you know,
whatever.
I might be a conflict.
I can't take it to the level of truly wishing that level of misery.
You know,
they haven't won it since 1969 at me.
But you be honest with yourself.
This is what I think when you realize if you're a problem fan,
where you're taken to the point where you're really just did,
I like the point that I've taken it.
Um,
where it's just no fun to be a sports fan where you literally take it to the
point where you don't want a,
like I remember like the,
the,
I probably age like 11 years after the Red Sox won in 2004 every year,
praying for the Yankees to never win another fucking world series select that
wasn't going to happen,
you know,
$200 million every fucking year on the table,
plus a fucking great organization is going to happen.
Um,
it's just too much fucking energy.
So my team is out of it.
I have done shit talking,
and even if the jets fucking lose,
I'm,
I'm not gonna do that to you because you beat my team and that,
and that's,
you know,
that's a fucking bitch move.
I'm not going to do it so seriously from the bottom of my jet hating heart.
Congratulations to all you guys.
You deserve it and joy.
You're fucking week and uh,
no,
this,
that you guys next week now carry the pressure of being,
or the only thing that stands in the way of a date,
rapists possibly going on to win his third super bowl championship.
Dude,
Ben Roethlisberger quietly,
very quietly.
I mean date rape charges really drown out a lot of on the field success.
Let's be fair,
very quietly,
uh,
could join the ranks of as far as I know,
if he wins his third one,
he's on the only,
he's with Tom and Troy Aikman.
They're the only other guys who have won three.
Right.
And then there's only two guys have one.
Four is Montana in Bradshaw.
Am I correct?
Am I missing somebody?
I thought Jim Plunkett for half a second,
but that was Kenny Stabler and 77.
So,
uh,
Oh,
let me tell jet fans.
I gotta get,
I gotta I owe this to you guys.
I got to let you know all my misery.
Yeah.
So at the end of the show,
the show fucking ends and,
uh,
the end of the week and,
I took a bunch of pictures with fucking jet fans wearing jerseys and,
uh,
it was actually,
we,
it was actually ended up being a good time,
but the,
the best thing was afterwards,
you know,
Norton into tell left,
cause you know,
they live in New York.
They took off,
Bro was handed with hang out with some friends.
So I go back to my fucking room by myself,
no security,
no nothing like now,
like I needed it.
But I walked back through the catacombs,
the fucking good fellas way by myself just thinking about the loss.
All I hear is the sound of my shoes hitting the tile floor,
walking to that service elevator that looks like shit because they,
you know,
they move furniture in.
It went up to my floor.
Okay.
Went into this amazing suite that they had given me
by myself.
I sat there,
I ordered room service and by myself with the TV off and only one light on in
silence.
I ate a cheeseburger,
some French fries.
And I got,
uh,
some cheesecake for dessert
and I just sat there.
I couldn't put the TV on and I just sat there in silence and then it hit me and
I was like,
oh my God,
I have to do the podcast and relive this.
So there you go.
I hope you jet fans deserved not deserved.
[inaudible] jet fans enjoyed that.
And I,
I'm,
I apologize that I,
when I got off the plane that I didn't come home,
I didn't come right home and do a podcast I could have,
but I really wanted to make sure that I did it justice,
that I got a good night's sleep.
I didn't want to do a lame podcast.
That podcast last week sucked.
I was getting ready to leave as the worst podcast I think I've ever done.
And uh,
I wanted to make sure that I,
you know,
I tried to remember all of my misery because I really felt,
that's one of the joys of winning is when a loud mouth count from the other
team,
you know,
they're miserable.
So I hope I didn't leave any details out.
I got a couple of emails.
MMM.
I Dunno,
but here's what I wanted that somebody said,
there was a couple of things I thought was funny.
Some guy what a jets fan who went up to a
Foxboro.
Oh,
you know what?
I have,
I have a feeling,
I'm just worried.
I'm not going to end up talking about the amazing look.
Can I just talk about how great Atlantic City was and why you guys have to see
this show?
Because I think we're going to take it to Connecticut at one of the casinos up
there.
And even if we don't,
if things don't work out,
which I know they're going to,
cause it was a fucking,
I want to thank everybody who came out to the shows.
It was really a fucking event.
Um,
and I don't overhype shows that I'm on,
but it was arguably one of the best comedy show easily that I've been on in the
last fucking 10 years.
And it's the strongest tour I've,
I think I've ever been on.
I mean,
those opie and Anthony ones were fucking amazing.
Those were amazing though.
Uh,
especially that night in Philly.
That's what's so funny about those fucking idiot Philly fans.
If you saw the email,
the lineup that night was Patrice O'neil,
Robert Kelly,
Tracy Morgan,
Ralphie made Jim Norton,
me,
who else was out there,
I'm going to forget Bob set.
It was fucking insane.
It was like one of the,
you know,
when those rock and roll hall of fame shows where they bring out like fucking
all these musicians and stick them on the stage and then somehow it always
sucks.
Is it ever good when you have 58 guitarist in 19 drummers that never,
it never sounds good.
And then they always play like mama kin or some fucking standard,
um,
hail,
rock and roll or some stupid shit that the we,
this is what is the first show.
And we played,
we was chicks d,
um,
except it was actually a great show.
But um,
this is,
so,
this will be the strongest one that I've been on since the ONA virus tour and a
opie and Anthony came down to,
and it was fucking great.
I was hanging out with both of them.
Um,
Anthony is absolutely fucking hilarious and there needs to be a documentary made
about people who played blackjack.
He came,
he came in from playing blackjack and he had sweat under his armpits.
Like he had been playing full court basketball in a turtleneck sweater.
Um,
it was awesome.
And I went over and watched him gamble and he was hilarious.
He was cursing out this fucking retard who didn't know how to,
didn't know how to gamble.
He fucking hit on 17,
went over and then the dealer got 21.
And uh,
I swear to God,
if Anthony killed him right then and there,
I,
I would've,
I would've become an accessory to murder.
Not In that I would have helped them kill him,
but I definitely would have helped to hide Anthony from the authorities.
Um,
do you mind if we come in Mr. Byrd?
Ah,
yeah.
But Warren,
yes,
we do.
Ah,
yeah,
just a,
just stay out of the bedroom.
Uh,
it's not really cleaned up.
Um,
anyways,
it was an unbelievable night.
And,
uh,
I don't know when we're going to do the show again,
but I have to tell you if you get a chance to see any of those three fucking
guys like Jim Norton's at that is the funniest I've ever fucking seen them.
Dave Attell is a fucking beast at Jim Brewer.
I'm telling you,
has one of the top 10 funniest fucking bits I've ever seen.
Uh,
obviously I'm not gonna,
you know,
ruin what the fuck it is.
But it starts off,
I was standing up watching him and by the time he was done,
I was slumped down.
I made us a fucking dirty casino rug.
If I could have fucking been laying on the ground laughing,
I would have.
But I was actually,
you know,
I was crouching down.
You ever see like when they gamble in China,
you know how they crouched down?
I was sorta sitting like that,
but I was fucking dying laughing,
like lean sideways into the wall.
This is our funny,
the joke was I actually was downstairs in the green room at one point and called
Nia while Jim was on stage and you could hear the show and I put the phone up to
the bit and she was dying laughing.
So if you guys get a chance to see any of them,
go on their websites,
go see them because,
uh,
it was just a fucking unbelievable weekend and I really,
really hope that we get to do it again and a,
and I want to thank Jim Norton for putting the whole thing together.
It's just a great idea.
And the fans were fucking amazing.
They were quiet.
They would laugh and then they,
then they would be quiet and let you set it up.
I felt like I was working at the cellar,
you know where you are,
just a great comedy room,
but it was this fucking 2100 Cedar Conference Room.
So,
um,
I hope you guys all had a great time.
I've got ridiculous emails about people telling me how funny the show was.
And I got like three emails from people telling me that was the first comedy
show they ever went to.
Um,
well,
all I can say is you pick the fucking right one.
So that's it.
So I'll let you guys know when we're going to be doing more.
Um,
all right,
so here's,
here's an email I got from a jet Fan who went up to Gillette stadium.
All right?
Uh,
pat fans are all scumbags who shop at ll bean.
Be Honest,
Patriot fans.
If you really remove yourself from the situation and you go buy a patriots
tailgate,
you know,
you know those fucking boots that are like,
they're like leather on top,
but they're made out of rubber on the bottom.
They'll shoot those boots are actually the shit.
Yeah,
we are a bunch of groups.
The same way.
If you go down to giants stadium,
it's like the fucking Jersey shore
meets,
uh,
you know,
those Artie Lange looking guys,
and I'm not trashing already leg because look at me.
I am a pasty face and back from Boston.
Um,
w you know,
we really are the faces of our state.
When I think of New Jersey,
I definitely think of on on Artie Lange type of a guy and thought when you think
a of Massachusetts don't you think about about some Conan O'brien,
bill burr looking fucking high.
E T t t t H.
I g J Tattoo.
Um,
so I'm not going to lie with you and I'm not going to say that we aren't
scumbags up there.
Uh,
we are told that got is just um,
uh,
just got in from Foxborough.
The experience was a good time,
expected some heckling going and uh,
made it out without getting hassled to hard overall was an awesome experience.
Watching all pat fans empty the stadium before the game was over.
My section was packed with jets.
Fans felt bad for the guy and his daughter who was surrounded on every side,
I guess by jet fans.
I'm not sure if it's Foxboro or NFL fans in general that are just degenerates
scumbags since I've only been to the Meadowlands prior to this for NFL Games.
But here's a small list of Shit I saw throughout the day.
I saw a guy in his girlfriend get real racist with one jets fans sitting in
front of them.
Uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's Boston until he spit beer on the wrong group of people.
And it turned into a pats fan verse pats fan fight.
You know,
funny that is because I've always resented Gillette stadium and the lighthouse
and the way they paved over the,
the scumbag experienced that going to a patriots game used to be over in Foxboro
stadium.
I hated how when we became a championship team,
all those corporate seats and all those fucking white collar douchebags who
started showing up,
it was a fucking keg party from 19 fucking 70 right through most of bill
Parcells time.
Not until we started winning championships and a,
the shit started.
Turn it around that all of a sudden there was this expecting to win vibe and
everybody started acting classy.
The bottom line is no fans,
no fans are classy.
Um,
unless you're winning,
then when you're winning,
it's easy to be like,
you know,
they just a bunch of classes,
people,
you know,
what kind of behavior is that?
Um,
it's like,
dude,
why don't you look into your fucking closet?
[inaudible]
remember how you acted?
It's like Yankee fans.
Remember that Shit.
It was always red feather.
Red Sox fans are scumbags.
We have no class and blah,
blah,
blah.
And this is all why the Yankees were winning.
And then I remember when a rod slap the ball out of a,
was it Bronson or royals glove?
And the call went against him for the first time in history.
The Yankees got caught cheating.
You know,
if they're all the years of polling home runs into the fucking stands and
leaning into balls during,
uh,
when you're picked off,
they've call finally went against him and the Yankee fans,
these classy fucking metropolitan.
We live in the Paris of United States littered the fucking field with fucking
trash.
All right,
so there you go sir.
So yes,
let me,
let me just finish.
He says,
uh,
Buh Buh,
Buh,
Buh.
I saw dude cut off an entire line of track it and throw beers at someone's car.
This is after the game
or maybe it was before the game.
Who knows?
And when confronted threatened the dude and said he was going to get is get.
And I also saw a bunch of Douche bags on the way on the way out on that shitty
two lane highway guilty as charged route one baby spiking bears at people's cars
in dead stopped traffic looking to the Ford looking forward to the podcast and
gloating all week.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Um,
yeah,
no,
if you go,
if you go around the league,
yeah.
A sports fans or if they're losing their,
yeah,
they are scumbags.
Nobody.
Nobody's a good loser,
you know.
But there are definitely worse ones.
And someone actually asked me
because uh,
it was one patriots fan.
I liked this guy.
He was pissed at all the pats fans that left.
Um,
and I know a lot of jets fans are go.
Yeah,
the fucking lame ass fucking fans.
It's,
I'll fuck you.
You Green faggots.
You do it too.
Everybody does it.
And the only those people who stay,
those are die hard fans.
And if you noticed,
it's like 26 fucking people.
Okay?
You know those years when your team is like one in 15 in 2014 and there's 26
people at the game and you know when your team is supposed to win some big
playoff game and then they,
they fucking lose and you're so embarrassed and,
but there's in this,
just that same 26 people,
that's the die hard fan.
And the only reason why they make the stadiums that fucking big is for the good
times when all the fairweather fags show up.
That's why.
And you,
you saw how many die hard fucking Patriot fans they are.
There's the same level as diehard jet fans.
I'm telling you with that little fireman walkout,
he wasn't,
would most jet fans walk out then that 45 be honest.
You Green country 45 to three d drubbing if that took place down in the meadow
lands,
Huh?
I know hoe do.
I would've stayed.
Oh,
I would have been there with the hero going,
don't worry,
I'm still here for you.
You're full of shit.
You would have been out there on the fucking awful Jersey Turnpike,
y'all would have left.
I got so many emails of people telling me they shut off the game and discussed
all that type of shit.
All right,
so shut the fuck up.
Most people are fair weather.
Fuck it,
fan.
So,
uh,
you know,
pet fans don't suck pat fans or just a,
they're an example of what a most fans are.
So I don't think you have any,
right.
Getting mad at an athlete.
If he doesn't sign your autograph,
sign you a fucking autograph.
You know,
because most of you,
if they're down 45 to three or 28 fucking 21 down by seven onside kick,
where the fuck were you?
You're already on route one,
so you have no right getting mad at him.
But uh,
that's what sports fans do.
They all suck.
Look at all those giant fans getting met.
They have the nerve to get mad at Tom Kauflin and at and ask if he should be
removed.
The guys like two and a half years removed,
three years removed from beating and undefeated 17 point favorite in the
Superbowl.
And now everybody's acting like the game passed him by.
MMM.
I Dunno.
So I know this has been pretty much all sports this week.
It had to be,
it had to be,
uh,
but Patriot fans.
Okay.
A lot of you as zoned out from watching ESPN and all the hype about this
patriots team,
you gotta understand what Belicheck did this year is he's rebuilding a fucking
monster.
And the fact that we were able to get as far as we did with the team,
that we had that awful fucking defense to somehow go 14 and fucking too,
when you let up 24 fucking points.
I can't wait to run into this fucking dickhead down at the comedy store,
another Patriot's fan who
was,
do you know what I hate wins when you have a sports debate in somebody who has a
point.
Okay.
And not only did they not wait for you to finish,
they say their point and then they just keep repeating it.
He goes,
patriots are going to win it,
man.
They're going to win the fucking super bowl bell.
Bill Belichick has got these guys.
I go,
wait a minute to wait a minute.
That letting up like the defense is like last in everything in the league,
three quarters of season he goes,
stats don't mean not to stats on me not to and I might do the letting up.
24 to 26 jack told me nothing.
She had told me not to now do to stats don't mean everything.
I love Peyton manning.
They don't mean everything,
but you know you can't ignore that.
I can't wait to fucking run into that guy.
I'm just going to walk up to him.
We stare at told me no eating.
She has told me 93 and of course he won't remember and then I'll just look like
a psycho.
Is he drinking again?
Speaking of which people I am 93 fucking days,
93 fucking days into uh,
into this hundred day John.
I got seven.
Oh,
actually,
I'm sorry,
I'm 94 days to go.
So next week,
the Monday morning podcast,
I will be a hundred days in and a,
I'm actually going to the Bruins,
uh,
La Kings.
So just in case you think I'm going to retire as a sports fan,
uh,
I'm not,
I have an odd sense of fucking relief.
I Dunno.
Maybe this podcast was like Cathartic.
I know.
I have no idea what and um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Am I going to be able to watch it next week?
I think Jay,
I think rex Ryan might be that,
you know,
when they say,
I tell you,
hey buddy,
if he played for you,
you'd fucking love them.
You know,
when they say it about off Samuelson and I say,
no,
I wouldn't.
Uh,
there's something about rex.
He reminds me of all the meat had friends I had when we used to go out,
drink it when I was younger,
you know?
Yeah.
But he's very hard to like,
he's very fucking hard to like,
you know,
he's fat.
I,
and I was really,
you know what it was about that guy.
Did you guys,
I don't know if it was made,
did you guys notice that he was losing weight rapidly the entire year because of
that lap band surgery and then right after that patriots loss,
he kind of leveled off for half a second and maybe put on a few pounds.
Did you notice that?
Do you realize like the level of m and m's that guy was eating,
you know,
after his,
I don't give up,
play them again like that.
[inaudible] he was trying to fucking calm down his mind.
Um,
that was one thing I was looking at.
I was like,
Oh man,
I hope this guy is losing his fucking mind and I just really don't want to lose
to these guys.
And we did.
And Ah,
with fucking hurt me.
It was like the end of Braveheart,
except I did cry out
and I didn't yell freedom,
but it definitely began with an f word.
All right,
there we go.
That's the end of that bullshit.
So let's get on with the other rest of the podcast people.
I am going to be in Arlington,
Texas.
Oh,
how funny is this?
I actually have an opportunity to go to the Superbowl this year,
which just trait change drastically because this jets one,
not that I don't have a ticket,
but there's no fucking way I'm going to go there if the jets are in it.
Uh,
I actually,
I might go cause I think I'm gradually getting past this shit,
you know,
come on Super Bowl and fucking Dallas.
That'd be awesome.
Um,
yeah,
and that's also,
you know,
if I'm back on the sauce,
that could be a really good fucking time.
You know,
by the way,
is that jet fan who's a fireman?
Is he actually a fireman?
And if he is,
when exactly does he fight fires because he's on all the home and away games.
How much money is he making as a firefighter that he can afford to do that?
Is it one of those gay things where he's living the way that the,
the fucking team,
the ownership or he's one of our super fans and the,
he gets like free season tickets.
Um,
is he part of the nine 11 clause?
Is that what it is?
Because he has a fireman hat on that,
you know,
they're like,
okay,
well we can't make this guy buy tickets.
He's a firefighter.
We all feel fucking horrific after nine 11,
let's fucking Hook this guy up at guys like one of the luckiest sports fans
ever.
Although I do notice they always stick them down in the corner of the end zone.
They don't quite hook them up on the 50 yard line.
Do they?
Um,
is he a fireman?
I have no idea.
I've been making fun of that guy all weekend.
I do know that he's very close with his boyfriend who puts them on his shoulder.
I still maintain that jet fans.
I will not back down on that if that was my fucking son.
Don't you ever,
ever put another man on your fucking shoulders with fireman's hat?
Do you understand me?
If you got a fucking mustache,
I would never talk to you again.
Do you understand me?
Huh?
Hey,
fucking talking to you.
As long as you carry my fucking last name.
All right.
They go to your room and think about it.
Um,
all right,
let's try and get something out of here.
Let's try to get something fucking going on about this.
Uh,
right.
Where are we?
Oh,
here's a revenge story in this one is disgusting.
All right.
If there's any women actually still listening to this podcast and for,
I did fucking an hour about a goddamn football game.
All right.
Revenge story.
Uh,
and I wrote gross in parentheses.
Okay.
Um,
I don't know if you still do those revenge stories anymore,
but I thought I'd pass mine along anyway.
All right.
I had this roommate in college who would chew loudly off.
That's,
that was one of my big pet peeves in life.
If you're a fucking adult and you eat with your mouth open,
I really think I should be able to leak legally.
Fucking stab you in the juggler with the utensil you're eating with.
Be it a chop stick.
A fork,
a fucking spoon.
I'm going to fucking spoon in there.
I will butter knife.
Slowly.
Fucking saw my way into that.
Um,
he would chew too loudly.
Scream into the phone when I was trying to watch TV.
Leave the toilet seat up when there were lady over and generally gross out my
girlfriend with his caveman like habits between that and his constant messages.
Uh,
I was having to clean up.
I got fed up after awhile.
I'm talking,
did nothing.
So I had to get creative since we shared a bathroom,
we also shared the toilet paper.
All right people,
I'm giving you an opportunity to hit stop right now.
All right,
you can hit stop.
You can hit pause.
You can fast forward.
It's probably gonna take me another minute.
Okay.
Have you done it?
Cause I'm going to start reading in three,
two.
I took the role into my room,
unraveled it and with my girlfriends assistant drip,
some leftover Tj's on it.
Let me read that sentence again.
I took a role into my room,
unraveled it,
and with my girlfriends,
assistant assistance drip,
some leftover.
TJ's on it.
I made sure to space it out every few sheets so that it was throughout the role
in,
in a small enough quantity that wasn't obvious.
Just exactly how did you do that?
Will you fucking choking your cock on choking,
choking on chunking,
chunking?
Is that what you were doing?
Did you have a fucking Turkey based or this is disgusting.
This is fucking disgusting.
So he left a small enough quantity so it wasn't obvious the satisfaction of
knowing that when he white,
he would be rubbing my semen into his ass,
made the annoying habits far less annoying after.
After that,
whenever he would chew loudly or be annoying,
my girl and I would think of what we'd done and just start laughing though that
knowing that I had planted my seed inside of him,
so to speak,
highly recommended this to,
I highly recommend this to anyone who has an annoying rent.
A roommate.
Ed has never been tested a Po as and as tested negative for HIV.
Dude,
that is fucking disgusting.
First of all,
how do you know when he went in there and wipe disasters?
Why are you thinking he's sticking his finger up his ass?
And,
uh,
what did you do when you went in and had to take a dump?
Yeah.
You obviously brought in some different toilet paper.
Did you have like your ear up to a glass waiting to hear the sound of fucking
shit hitting the toilet water.
And how did your girlfriend bring you to climax with that toilet paper right
there?
She just rub you out like it was a job,
Eh,
let's just fucking disgusting man.
That's really one of the creepy ones I've ever gotten a youtube videos this
week.
I only have one of them.
Um,
because I,
I seriously,
uh,
like I said,
I was flying back from Atlantic city and I,
I didn't have time to go through all the youtube,
so I apologize.
I only have one,
uh,
the left rights.
I'm on crack.
It's actually a really cool music video.
A silly song.
Uh,
maybe you can attest to this sort of what?
Happy one.
Let me,
let me do the,
I've got a couple of advice and then I'm going to tap out here.
Uh,
all right,
advice.
I know this girl.
I've known her for a bit.
Uh,
we're friends.
We've been for a while.
Okay,
now this one.
You know how everybody always trashes me for the way I fucking read.
I know I suck at reading,
but I have to let you know.
This is all in lower case and there's absolutely no punctuation whatsoever.
I don't know if this guy text messaged this or what,
but this is not my fucking fault.
Let me try my best to read this.
All right,
Bill.
I know this girl.
I've known her for a bit and we're friends.
No period.
We've been for awhile,
comma.
Anyway,
about a month ago,
I asked her out on a date and she said yes,
comma,
continuing the sentence.
He doesn't have periods.
He just says calm as lowercase.
I took her out and we had fun.
No period.
We talked.
Shit
was Hunky Dory.
No Comma,
we kissed it.
No period.
It was awesome.
First date,
it was an awesome first date.
Hey,
there's a period,
no capital letter.
Then I,
I barely fucking heard from her.
No.
Period.
I was running around like a fucking jackass.
No period.
Just trying to talk to her,
Eh,
I'm sorry.
The,
I guess it keeps going.
Just trying to talk to her and when we would talk it was fine.
Oh,
there's a period I was beating myself up going crazy.
No,
period.
I was some piece of shit.
Anyway,
I pulled myself together and I asked her out again.
She once again said,
yes.
Awesome.
Right.
Well not your fucking lack of punctuation.
That's not awesome.
So we go out again,
went cool again.
I didn't kiss her this time.
I don't know it was just off,
but any way,
comma,
that was no punctuation and all of that.
You fucking Dick.
Once again,
I was fucking,
once again,
I fucking didn't hear a thing,
so I said,
fuck it.
I don't need this right now.
And we just went back to being friends.
Never talked about it.
Just let it lay.
Fucking see double at this point.
Anyway,
lately I've been talking to her a lot.
Like I said,
like I said,
we're friends,
but she's very clearly been flirting with me and I honestly have been flirting
back.
I still like the girl.
No,
period.
nothing,
but I just don't know if it's worth it,
you know,
period.
No question mark.
She's got a lot of drama.
She's one of these girls that gets drunk at a party and cries.
Then ask people if she's pretty,
which she really fucking is like really hot dot,
dot,
dot.
Ah,
but I do like her,
I just don't know if I should put myself through this shit again.
What do you think bill?
I legitimately,
legitimately would like your advice slash opinion.
Um,
okay.
The first thing I would do,
I'd get some sort of spellcheck.
I would get some sort of uh,
um,
phonics or some sort of shit to teach you how to write.
All right?
People,
I know I suck at reading out loud,
but can,
can you do me a fucking solid?
I'm not reading any more fucking emails that,
that are like this.
All right.
Because this is literally is I'm starting to lose my fucking eyesight.
Um,
so what do I think?
Yeah.
Okay.
This is what I think.
I think you should definitely not get into a relationship with this girl,
this girl,
this girl is a fucking nightmare.
All right?
There's all kinds of red flags.
I don't know what happened to her and I can tell you right now,
you don't want to find out what's happening to her,
what happened to her.
You don't want to find out in that you don't want to have feelings for this
girl,
all right?
And when the other fucking bag of shit hits the floor and your heart is
underneath that,
you,
you don't,
you don't.
You don't let a girl like this break your heart,
all right?
You can see it from a mile away.
She is a fucking mess.
All right?
There's plenty of great girls out there.
You're a young guy.
Go find one.
All right?
Find a girl,
you know,
make a list of shit.
All right?
One of the big things,
if you want to find a really good girl is find one who has a great relationship
with her parents.
Hopefully they're still together,
all right?
That's another good thing.
Start with that,
but as I sit in there,
you have created,
they've got low self esteem issues,
you're going to kill a decade,
are your fucking life trying to build them up and it,
you know what it's going to be.
It's going to be fucking exhausting.
All right?
And then because she doesn't think she's pretty,
she might act out sexually,
um,
for some sort of,
you know,
okay.
I don't know,
like
Geez,
I just really have an hour and six minutes in here.
Just,
you know,
some sort of affirmation that she is pretty okay.
So what do I think you should do?
All right,
well,
if you're a well adjusted guy,
you'll just walk away from the situation and say that I'm not gonna just banger
and use that as a fucking Nacho.
My bed to make my ego feel good and I'm not going to hurt this person.
But if you're,
how most people are your age,
I would just say bang her and then,
uh,
I dunno,
it's,
it's going to be ugly.
If you want to bang this girl,
I got to tell you,
don't let your heart get involved.
At a,
I dunno,
not,
not having seen her.
I've seen how watch she is and being older and more mature,
I would say just walk away and go find some,
well adjusted hottie that's,
unless you just want to bank somebody,
but then you can do that.
You know what it's about this thing you don't want.
I don't like.
There's too much fucking history.
You gotta be able to leave.
You gotta be able to fucking go out the side door.
If you just gonna to bank somebody,
you can't have this.
Well,
we were friends at first and then it became romantic.
Then we went back to being friends and then we fucked.
And it's just a fucking nightmare.
Yeah.
I'd find someone else to fuck.
But if you don't give a shit,
yeah,
I banger.
But by no means don't develop any sort of feelings for her.
All right,
there you go.
There's my advice.
I'm going to do one more and then that's it.
All right.
This one has punctuation.
So if I fuck up,
this one is on me.
Uh,
hey bill,
first of all,
if I want to thank you for your breakup advice I listened to.
I think this is just a thank you here.
I listened to the podcast a few weeks ago and heard this guy's story about
getting dumped on Christmas Eve.
Oddly enough,
I was also at the end of a relationship with a girl who had,
who had had a kid.
She waited until a week after new year's when I was out of town,
a center flowers because I could tell something was off.
Something was up.
I mean,
and I had been gone a lot recently.
She called when I got off work and confirmed my suspicion.
I don't need to get into all that shit.
It happened.
And uh,
the point is I just listened to your podcast after it all happened and decided
that's how it had to be.
No point in screwing anything else up in my life.
No,
no point in worrying about anything.
Get back to the gym and focus on finishing school and my career.
That's right.
There you go.
That's a great fucking move.
That's a self esteem move right there.
You're going to find somebody else.
You're going to get somebody better.
Go get in great shape and uh,
get your career going.
Phenomenal.
Fucking move.
Uh,
thanks for the words of encouragement.
I think they did some good big fan man.
I bought you a DVD and I'll continue a support of the podcast.
Well,
thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
And uh,
thank you to everyone who's been listening to my podcast.
And again,
congratulations to the jets,
their organization and the fans.
You deserved it.
You went into our stadium,
you kicked our ass to the point that all you saw how many true Patriot fans
they're fucking are.
Um,
but there are just as many true jet fans to be honest with yourself.
Be honest with yourselves
when they suck.
Do you watch them?
Do you think?
I watched a Celtic game from like 2002 to 2006.
I didn't.
All right.
I jumped right back on that bandwagon.
I am a die hard Bruin fan.
Die Hard Patriot Fan.
I was a die hard red sox fan.
But uh,
you know,
what happened was they won the world series and I felt like a degenerate gambler
who finally made a big score and I just walked away from the table and I was
like,
that's it.
I'm up.
I'm buying my little fucking houseboat.
I'm going to throw down the anchor and drink Pina coladas the rest of my life.
See you later.
Thanks for the memories.
And I haven't been able to get back into them,
um,
since I gotta be honest with you.
And uh,
who else has left and the Celtics,
the Celtics,
I got back into the Celtics.
You know,
I'm not a big basketball fan.
I'm not a big professional basketball fan for the simple fact that the final
three minutes takes two hours and 17 minutes.
I don't like how they travel.
And that's all I,
they travel all the time,
all the fucking time.
When I want you to NBA game,
that's all I do is I just sit there watching both teams,
even my team,
and I just go,
that's a fucking,
how do they,
how do they not sit the fuck the guy fucking took that was three and a half
steps travel.
Uh,
that that's,
you know,
I'm just not into it,
but uh,
I do like it when the Celtics and the Lakers are good.
That's when it's great.
That's the rivalry.
I like fucking watching the same way.
It sucks if the Canadians are awesome in the Bruins are bad or the other way
around.
I don't want the Canadians to suck.
I want it to be awesome.
The Bruins,
to be honest,
I like the fucking colliding.
Add a and that's it.
And Patriots fans keeping fucking heads up,
especially the 26 year who actually stuck around to the end of the fucking game.
All right,
keep your heads up.
Bill Belicheck is fucking the best guide them coach.
And um,
you know what he did starting for rookies on defense,
what he did this year was fucking phenomenal.
We laid an egg in the worst possible time,
but uh,
you know,
don't be a Douche and puts your pad skier away for the fucking year.
All right?
Don't be like that.
Don't be like,
or be like that.
Who gives a fuck?
You think these athletes give a shit about you?
You know,
they did not going to walk by in and fucking airport with their fucking $10,000
headphones on.
Actually.
They're not even going to walk by you on the head and at the fucking airport
cause they got their own goddamn plane
at Jesus.
You know,
this podcast could really be endless because I never run out of shit to bitch
about.
And that's a podcast for this week.
Uh,
that's it.
I will talk to you next week.
God bless all he is.
Even the jet fans,
you fucking green cons and everybody go fuck yourself.
I'll see ya.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].